So, tell me about Cuddle
Sanctuary.
Cuddle Sanctuary is a social
experience that welcomes healthy
human touch.
I associate cuddling with sex.
Like, I don't know how you
separate it.
If you feel some arousal coming
on, just shift your position.
What if when I shift, I go
like...
[ Laughs ]
[ Grunts ]
This is how I shift.
So, I'm gonna try a class.
Okay. Let's do it.
Let's do it. Let's cuddle.
Franzblau: So, let's talk about
the many different options of
things you can try.
The first one would be spooning.
Does anybody feel like demoing
the spoon?
You're in?
You're in.
Coming in for a landing.
Is this missionary of cuddling?
The only problem I'm really
having is that I'm concerned
where my phone is.
Do you mind if I check my
e-mail, bro?
Um, yes.
But now that I can't check my
e-mail, I just...
I want to let you know that the
rest of the time I'm gonna be
thinking about checking my
e-mail.
[ Laughter ]
The next option that you have
for paired practice is called
companioning.
I guess I'm just gonna go ahead
and sit next to you.
Cool.
[ Chuckling ] That's it.
Um, this is it?
[ Laughs ] Yeah.
In seventh grade, this would've
blown my mind.
We could do back to back.
I could just spin around and
then sort of...
Let's do it.
And this is kind of it.
All right.
It's just sort of like a way for
people to chill out and talk.
It's very, uh, "Fault in Our
Stars."
So, I'm going away this summer.
Do you think we'll keep in
touch?
Yeah.
I don't want to go.
What if you meet some other
girl?
Then it's over.
[ Laughter ]
You're crazy.
Is that good?
Is that what we would talk
about, things like that?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Cool.
I'm still thinking about my
phone.
You're like the teddy bear I
always wanted.
You wanted a biracial,
polyamorous teddy bear?
That's weird.
Is that your belt?
I'm not wearing a belt.
Is that, like, a button?
No, they're --
they're just pajamas.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, I love this.
But I do want to [bleep] you.
[ Laughter ]
How often do you...
fall in love?
This isn't really the place for
that.
Your pajamas tell me otherwise.
[ Laughs ]
Will you read me my e-mails?
Woman:
"Dear beloved friend, permit me
my desire to go into business
relationship with you.
I am daughter of late Al Bedarri
of Libya, whom was murdered
during the recent civil war in
Libya.
Before his death, my late father
was a strong supporting
member..."
Would you like to hold hands
with me and eye-gaze?
What are your intentions with
me?
Uh, I don't know.
I'm just, like, lost in your
eyes.
They're just like --
I-I feel like I'm, like, staring
at the universe.
The universe?
Yeah.
That's a little much.
You should follow me on
Instagram.
Okay. Sounds good.
That means a lot that you said
that.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Uh...
Thanks for gazing.
It was really nice.
I love you.
Love you too.
Thank you for having me, you
guys.
I seriously get what you're
saying now.
This isn't about sex at all.
I don't want to have sex with
any of you.
Like, when are we gonna [bleep]
Seriously?